someone told me you were given a second
chance at life and I said is that what
this is that I don't I regret it I
regret having the second chance 202 was
when we heard what we thought with the
DJ sampling noise of the government and
shotgun going off like a DJ sample horns
going off in their songs so she says so
consecutive is bahahaha we genuinely hit
the ground I grabbed and drag 1 best
ride for protection
Oh
people wiggle through made it out people
hop the fence we went through a hole see
that's how you got out that's how I got
out that's when I said okay so I held
the door with that guy for 10-15 seconds
max max
you
it's the first time actually have blank
rooms flying to stairs blank lose
everything talking to people is it
really numb right now we're gonna go see
counseling right now but I feel like I
did it's gonna just go in one ear and
out the other because this is still so
surreal I don't feel like this is
happening